they were threatening us we were going
to blow your brains that made me think
that they had guns you just
trust whatever they tell you
[Music]
my name is mercy mafu i live in south
africa was urunata
i work in the ministry we work with the
young people
it's been three years now since my
husband passed away
he was a minister and we worked together
in the ministry
he was the key person especially here in
the area
most of the people they knew him
they worked with him i mean we worked
hand in hand
the week we were kidnapped i remember
very clearly because
there was a sheep at richard's bay
we went to that actually we had a
child that we had adopted that stayed
with us so we really wanted him to
experience that
we stayed there until it was late
and then after that we went for dinner
and
came home went to bed as
usual and then it was like in the
middle of the night when we heard
somebody just
kicking the door i mean they just the
whole
door just fell in i just couldn't
believe
that somebody was in the house and of
course
somebody was standing right there i
started screaming
my husband started really trying to
fight with this guy
and i'm thinking i have i had a push
knife at the back of
in the house and then i touched it
and i said no i'm gonna miss him
and he's they're gonna kill us because i
felt well i knew they wouldn't
he was just not by himself and then
after he was done with him he came and
just smacked me tell me to keep quiet
they
tie us and the first thing that they
wanted were the keys for the cars
because they knew that there were cars
in the garage
and so i gave them
all the keys those are the cars for the
ministry
they were ready to take whatever they
wanted but they were taking all the cars
that belongs to the mission and then
after they did that
they said well let's go said well please
you have all the keys you can take all
the cars you can take
whatever you want but leave us they said
no
we will take you we will drop you on the
way
then you can come back home but they
said they will drop us at the mall
they threw him in the car and i hang on
real tight and then after that it was
time to go
well they were busy talking they were
saying it's time it's time
somebody was just telling them that it's
time to get out we were just praying
loud
when we left here we just prayed loud
we went to the gas station fill up the
cars
we are still praying and then
when we were just not too far
all of a sudden we heard them saying
because they were really communicating
the other car
capsized i don't know what's wrong with
that guy who's driving that car then all
of a sudden they came to us they say
stop praying
that's why this is happening of course
we did stop praying
but i mean we can stop praying
talking loud but we were still praying
another thing that they told us they
said we know we are not bad guys at all
this is the work we are at work right
now
so just like you wake up and go to work
this is the job we are doing this job so
we are not bad guys we are not gonna
rape you we are not gonna do any harm
to you unless you do something
they kept driving and talking
and being nice i mean they knew they
even knew that
isaiah was a diabetic so he had
they had his bag they gave me whatever
was in his bag
candy but we were sharing candy we were
we never saw their faces because
they they just told us that you don't
look at them
and the guys that were in with us in the
car really they
they didn't even have their faces
covered they were changing the
the drivers from here to pelhan daba we
had a different driver
and then from there we had another
driver so i could hear when they were
talking about those places
plus where i think when we were getting
to sotona bay
they said it was okay for me i could sit
up
in the car but not still with my head
down
then when we got to mongoose that's when
they started they left
the main road started using whatever i
don't know whether there was a dirty
road
whatever but it was just going down into
the bushes
it was kind of drizzling that morning
and then
we got stuck i think where we got stuck
there were people that came because
finally
they tried everything in with the car
he couldn't so they needed somebody to
push them out
so whatever happened because we were
told
to really go down we didn't see anything
but
you could hear that there were more
people there that
helped them to push out the car we drove
maybe about two
hours and then finally
the car stopped we were packed
and i could tell that they were relaxed
but
what was happening they would go out
and seems as if they had a meeting but
still was
we're not allowed to look at them
but they had something like a meeting
outside
when we were there there was something
like
a light behind us and all of a sudden
we had the gun shot and when we heard
that
we went under and then we heard somebody
screaming
get out of the car get out of the car it
was the police car
they tried because it was a real thick
bushy place where we were they couldn't
even so they
got out tried to chase them and
well we could they couldn't find them
these guys were gone
nowhere to be seen so finally
they came and they asked if we're the
owner of the car
and my husband said yes and then
he took us to the police car and then
the police policeman that was driving he
said
i am a christian i dreamed about this
that there were people that i needed to
help
in the morning i received this phone
call
of somebody telling us that there is a
car
that has been driven that way since i
had
this that dream about the people that i
needed to help
so we were just like you hear that there
are miracles they happened
but it's very very difficult to believe
that it
really happened but for me i felt like
you know god just took me
out from that thick bush because there
was
absolutely nobody who could know
where i was something
that i learned from this whole situation
i mean
to be fearful sometimes it just
traumatizes you
and you are unable to do anything just
because you are so fearful
but for me to know that god is in
control of my life
that has helped me even during this time
you